foreign
[Music]
my name is Mark ducop I'm the CEO and
co-founder of novazine and today I'm
going to talk about process modeling so
my talk will be entitled from
experiments data Hybrid models and
digital twins several up and down stream
success stories highlighting the
benefits of using advanced process
modeling
before we start with this topic
I quickly want to introduce myself again
or the company I'm working for so I said
we founded an oversign it's a spin-off
from Boku University in Vienna okay
University in Nevada has a department of
Biotech or biotechnology already since
30 years in the last 10 years we
intensively focused on process modeling
and from this knowledge we gained in
this field basically we founded the
company in 2019 mainly addressing early
stage process development to speed up
the development process by reducing the
experimental effort and during the talk
I will show you some highlights from our
work this is all published so you will
always find to the bottom right there's
a there's a quote which you can then go
to the internet and basically search for
this publication if you have more if
you're more interested in more details
or you can also write in an email
afterwards
okay so starting off uh uh how can we
basically what do we need to have better
bioprocesses so first of all we have to
understand our bioprocesses better so
that means we have to describe them in a
certain way in a certain qbd approach so
that we basically better understand how
input and output is connected the second
thing is basically that we need better
process scaling so you know this
basically we need to process upscale you
often have the issue that whatever you
develop in the smaller scale the ideal
set points do not hold true in the
larger scale and the third thing
basically what we want to do when we
look into the future is we also want to
have process control so basically we
want to interact with our process and in
case that something goes wrong we want
to know which screws to turn in order to
develop in order to get the process in
the right direction again for example to
maintain a certain quality attributes or
a certain title or whatever just to
bring it back and all of these three
things as you might notice are a
modeling topics so basically if you use
nice models you can have a faster
process understanding you can use these
models for process scale up and also you
need models for process control so that
basically with Nova sand where we have
division is basically to create a hybrid
modeling toolbox and we're going to
detail after what is hybrid modeling but
the idea is to have this hybrid modeling
toolbox and this basically is set by
experimental data so you have to perform
experiment in a certain way you have to
feed this information into the toolbox
the toolbox then learns from this
information and basically gives the
process engineer the understanding of
how input and output is connected that's
the first thing
and they said afterwards when we also
want to use these models not only for
understanding and for optimization but
also for control purposes we also have
to bring it back to the to the
manufacturing environment where we use
this type of models uh for process
monitoring and control purposes
uh today's talk I will have six
showcases for you for Upstream showcases
and two Downstream showcases and we're
basically all developed in this hybrid
modeling toolbox it will also be a link
provided at the end where you can
download this toolbox and you can test
it yourself on your own data to get an
idea of how this works
uh basically it helps you to get uh it
helps you to develop time resolved wire
process models it gives you a certain
process knowledge that helps you to
understand how input and output is
connected and you can take these models
for process optimization and asset
afterwards for control purposes and
already quite some pharmaceutical
companies use this tool to optimize
their processes
before I want to start with the modeling
task I want to highlight one really
crucial things because we always
encounter this that a lot of people
believe that the algorithms are the only
important thing to drive a valuable
process model but it's actually not so
the first thing before you start
modeling before you do anything is
questioning yourself what do you want to
do what is your what is the whole
modeling task for you wanted to process
optimization do you want to have a model
for process control what is the purpose
of all of this model based on that you
can then think about which experiments
to perform so what are the critical
process parameters I'm looking at you
can do this with um with a risk analysis
for example to investigate which of the
factors are really important and which
are less important than you think about
how which experiment to perform
afterwards you collect the data and when
I say collecting the data we're
collecting the offline and the online
data because there's value in both of
them and only after that step we are
then going in the direction of process
modeling so the first step the third
step in this process modeling is not
just about the algorithm but it's really
about the research question what do you
want to do then building the type of
experiments data process modeling and
based on that you can then use this
these models in a digital twin
environment where you can do in silica
process simulation to say okay what
would be my ideal process condition and
then you either go back to the lab and
perform your experiments or oh this is a
little bit off so take these models
basically for for scaling or for
manufacturing for visualization you can
take this type of models then
for for the for the error for the second
uh for the green line here
uh when we talk about Hybrid models what
does this mean basically are Hybrid
models bridge the gap between a
mechanistic understanding and data so as
we said we have to have a certain
understand we have to have a certain
idea what we want to predict from our
models what is the what is the the
output in this case we want to have
critical quality articles one and two
this one should be predicted by the
model and we have some critical process
parameters that that uh that fit into
this model
and then we have a mixture of a black
box the machine learning part
artificial neural network for example
and this artificial neural networks and
predicts or estimates some rates that
are then put into mechanistic
understanding so like a mass balances
which then at the end predict the
critical quality articles and by doing
so you have the advantage that you have
a precise identification with a smaller
amount of experiments you can use this
knowledge for process scale up and as I
said you can use the same type of models
for monitoring and control and all of
these showcases I will show you today in
detail for up and downstream topics
when talking about hybrid model what is
the what is the advantage of using
hybrid model so for example this is our
this is one of the first Publications
here I want to share with you today the
link is down there to the right what you
basically see here is we were interested
into describing a design space a
three-dimensional design space in a 20
liter microbial fermentation and we
wanted to describe basically how these
cells react to different inputs
based on an ordinary doe endpoint
description based on the Black Box
modeling and based on hybrid modeling
and when we do so and we compare it
basically to predict the biomass and to
predict the product at the end you see
here that the error for the for the
response surface model with a with an
ordinary OLS model is basically very
accurate in the range of the analytical
error and so it's the hybrid model but
the hybrid model has the advantage that
you model in this case the entire
process from the beginning until the end
you also capture the process Dynamics
and you incorporate knowledge that is a
lot of advantages and the errors in a
very similar range when you now look at
the product basically you see that the
error coming from uh from the OLS model
is in the range of 20 while the error
from the hybrid model is in the range of
10 the reason why is basically that with
the hybrid model we uh connect the
product formation to the specific to the
to the biomass so the more we know how
much biomass we have in our system the
better we can predict how much product
is expected at the end point therefore
we get the best uh a better Precision
with this hybrid model over the over the
other two the one I did not mention so
far is the Pure Black Box model so it
basically also describes the whole
process in a Time resolved manner but uh
the accuracy is not as high as from the
hybrid model
and by doing so you can do a
multi-dimensional optimization so you
basically get one model to predict or to
describe as many output parameters you
want to have in this case we only have
product in biomass but you could also
for example think about product quality
you could also model glucose propagation
over time all of these factors could be
taken into account and they are all in
this singing model that describes the
whole process at once second due to the
fact that you have this time resource
model you can then think about advanced
screening method like this intensified
this kind of experiment approach I will
go into detail afterwards but in a
nutshell basically it just helps you to
significantly reduce
amount of experiments to screen a
certain design space
and finally the model structures that
can directly be taken for monitoring and
control because yeah you just have to
put the input parameters in and then you
get a prediction for the output
parameters you're basically interested
in
so these are the six showcases I want to
show you today for Upstream showcases
into Downstream showcases starting
directly with the Upstream showcase
it's about model based process
optimization so here the idea is to
start with a certain amount of
experiment with a small amount of
experiments and then as quickly as
possible screening the whole design
space to find the optimum with as little
experimental effort as possible
so as that idea risk you have to think
about what do you want to predict what
are the critical process formats I want
to vary then you start with an initial
guess
you perform your experiment you create
your hybrid model and then you go into
this in silica simulator
which then basically simulates all of
the possible combination in this design
space
based on that the system tells you an
Optimum so what is the best favorable
condition you can you can have and then
you you look basically if you already
performed this experiment
or or if it's a new Optimum when it's a
new Optimum that means you have to
perform this experiment because you you
don't know it from the data yet and once
you perform this experiment you
basically take it into account and put
it again into the model structure and
then you're in this iterative Loop and
you just iterate through the design
space until the moment where you don't
get a new Optimum so basically your your
tools has a clear this is this is the
condition which is favorable and then if
you look and you already perform this
experiment you know that you're
basically you found the optimum and by
doing so you can Screen through the
design space and with this duplication
here for example we could reduce the
experimental effort on 27 experiments to
screen the whole design space down to
nine by by using this uh model based
design of experimental approach
and you can see this here in detail for
example so we started this set with five
initial experiments and then we just
iterated through the design space along
these orange dots and then found the
optimum in this case we modeled
space-time yield and you can see for
example in the first iteration where we
only have five experiments see that the
model is already very accurately
describing the biomass we see this in
green
but it's quite off for the for the
product so it means you take this
experiment P into account into the next
iteration put it into the algorithm and
do the same thing again and again and
again
and uh after iteration F basically you
finish this optimization and you found
your your Optimum process condition and
by doing so you can iterate through the
design space if you have the ability to
perform campaigns for example that you
can perform for experiments at a time
because you have a task keeper
of an ember system or something like
that and you can also think about what
would be the four best conditions to
learn as much as possible from the
design space to iterate through your
Optimum to your Optimum so that is the
first uh thing I wanted to share with
you again here there's the publication
down there just follow the link uh and
and read it in detail if you're if
you're interested so that's the that's
the first thing I wanted to show you
here when it's about process
optimization you don't have a lot of
ideas about your process and you just
start with some initial experiments the
second showcase I want to share with you
is uh it's about process
characterization
so it's more about uh you have a defined
design space you want to screen and here
you can use something like intensified
design of experiments how does this
basically work uh you can have you have
several approaches how you can screen
the design space the the most easy so
let's say the obvious one is to just
perform one of the experiments that that
are possible if you have a very large
design space or something above four
factors this might turn infeasible
because you have to perform that many
experiments that you just cannot you
will never finish it second one is
obviously the obvious one is then you
reduce your experimental effort by just
taking out experiments you see this in
this fractional approach where you just
reduce the experimental effort by just
taking points out but it's also quite
clear that this comes with the drawback
that you not able to describe the design
space in the same way because you
significantly reduce the amount of
experiments and the third one is this is
the approach I want to suggest here is
this intensified design of experiment
abroads what you do is you start with a
certain parameter combination so let's
say to the corner left and then during a
cultivation you change your process
parameter combination let's say to the
center point here and after a certain
time again you you change this parameter
combination again and by doing so it's
quite obvious that you can uh basically
put free x in this case put free
experimental parameter combination to
one experiment so you see that you only
perform nine experiments overall but you
pack 27 parameter combinations into a
single experiment into into pack three
parameter combinations into uh each
experiment that means you can screen 27
parameter combinations with only nine
experiments
and now when looking at the results
basically you see this here so we
created the hybrid model based on this
nine iron intensified design of
experiment runs which are these orange
dots and created the hybrid model and
then we took this model and applied it
to the static design of experimental
approach which is basically this uh
triangles this green triangles and you
see this is a prediction of the model
over the measured values and you see
when you when you create the hybrid
model in this nine ideally rounds yeah
for sure it's quite precise because it's
trained on this data but then when you
take basically the static doe data so
the runs where you do not change any
parameter combinations the classical
approach let's say this way you see that
the hybrid model is able to predict the
outcome of the static runs quite
accurately so in a nutshell you can
think about okay either you perform
this 27 experiment or 31 because we we
did some replicates or you perform nine
experiments to stream the design space
and it's quite obvious that the amount
of work you have to put into nine
experiments is significantly less
compared to the 31 experiments are
in the static and you see on to the left
is scatter plot and in the center on the
right there are some there are free runs
for example as an example for static
experiments with different outcomes and
different timings
and you can see how the hybrid model is
able to predict this outcome quite
accurately with the advantage that you
save almost 70 percent of experimental
effort
second which is maybe not so obvious
when you think about a model predictive
control approaches where you want to
change process parameter combination in
order to recover your process
you have to know basically how your
cells react to process changes and
somehow by applying this already during
a learning your model somehow
understands how quickly or how quickly
basically process parameter changes lead
to a certain quality change in your in
your responses
the third showcase I want to share with
you is a process scale up modeling here
in this case we took Cho culture and the
idea was to apply a model from Shake
class experiments and so to train a
model on Shake fast experiment and then
to apply it apply it on the 15 liter
scale so it's a factor of 50 scale up
and we wanted to predict basically how
good or we want to we want to apply the
knowledge from the small scale on the
large scale to find the optimum process
condition on the larger scale
uh and the only thing we had to do in
order to be able to describe the full
design space on the larger scale was to
take a Center Point cultivation to
recalibrate the model on the larger
scale and then it was able to predict
the outcome for all of the different
other parameter combinations
you can basically see this here so you
have again the Scatter Plots to the left
side left side top left is basically uh
the the viable cell density how how
accurate this is predicted for the for
the shake file experiment and to the
left bottom basically it's the product
so you see hybrid model was trained and
this runs quite accurately and then it
was predicting the outcome on the 15
liter scale so it's a little bit less
precise but still it's also very good
and you see also that the model is now
able to describe much higher uh product
formations for example well to the left
the maximum was 0.6 grams per liter only
to the right it was one gram per late
and this was a this was possible just
because we did the recalibration of the
center point
took this information into the hybrid
model and then it was able to describe
this larger scale
also quite accurately
the last Upstream showcase here I want
to show you is basically then when you
have such a model so you now created
hybrid model we now save the
experimental effort on the larger scale
how can we now take these models for uh
process monitoring and control purposes
we have a collaboration together with
Siemens in Vienna and what we basically
did is we set up our Siemens setup use
cultivation in this bioreactor down
there uh with a toe setup so to change
pH and temperature they also had some
Oscars measurement
they performed this experiment sent us
the data we created a hybrid model and
sent them back basically
the valuable information so the the pack
hybrid model in the dll file so the dll
file and contains all of the knowledge
of okay what what what is the outcome if
you change one of these input vectors
and then they put it into the sidebot
environment and we're able to basically
monitor uh the gluco sorry monitor the
biomass concentration in real time
during uh during next cultivations and
this is basically depicted here
so you see for example how the biomass
propagates uh over time in this disease
cultivation there was also there were
also some offline measurements
that
the soft tensor was working quite
accurately and you can you can use such
type of substance for manufacturing
purposes for for example induce yourself
or without a certain uh
at a certain concentration to Reliable
always get the
similar output at the end of your
cultivation
this is a typical application is that
for for a soft tensor and was
implemented in the in the living lab
uh in Vienna
the next thing I want to share with you
is a downstream showcase so here is
about ultra filtration flux prediction
so what we want to do here is to predict
basically the duration of an
ultrafiltration process as accurately as
possible
and the vision we had in mind basically
was to say okay we want to have the
process characterization of a certain
membrane with a certain product we want
to know in the whole design Space by
changing different parameter
combinations how quickly can we finish
such a process and how does it propagate
depending on the input parameter so we
had a set of product and membrane
combination
and then we chose cleverly chose our
design space when you remember what I
told you in the beginning when I said
it's not only about the algorithm it's
also about the design space this is
really crucial the experiments are as
crucial as the as the as the as the
modeling approach itself so it's not
just the algorithm that will solve the
issue it's really about thinking about
which experiments you have to perform in
order to get the maximum out we often
see from customers when we were at the
University I think a lot of you also
have the same impression that it's
rather starting soon with some
experiments and thinking about what
would be the ideal experiment in the
language you think about how to perform
the ideal experiments the better your
initial guess already will be so this is
a really underestimated underestimated
parameter so think about your
experiments as as much as possible
before you start them in with respect to
what you want to deliver at the end time
uh
when the last thing we want to do here
is basically to take this model stand
once we have the designs if we want to
take these models for uh to predict the
outcome of batch dff at batch tff uh
single pass language for filtration
entire filtration so that we have one
model that is able to describe all of
these four different uh unit operations
or operational modes in a singing model
uh when thinking about the fat patch
model basically what we did here is we
we changed uh the three parameter
combinations we were interested in is
the TMP uh the the cross flow and the
starting concentration of our of our of
our tiger protein and then we let an
estimate we let an artificial neural
network predict basically the flux at
each parameter combination and then we
put this flux into the mass balance and
based on this mass balance basically a
new concentration was predicted after a
certain in time interval and then we
take this we take this new concentration
and basically put it back into the into
the iterative loop and by doing so you
can get a multi-step ahead prediction
and you can predict basically the
duration of the process or the outcome
at the pros of this process depending on
your input parameters and this is a very
simple but clever structure in order to
uh to model such a such a process
and when we now look at the results we
see here for example the duration of
such uh of such a batch tff or fat batch
tff for you maybe to recap the
difference between a batch and the fat
batch tff is a search tank so any for
example are in the manufacturing side
and you have let's say a five liter tank
or a 10 liter tank but you have 20
liters to process you need to put this
remaining 10 liter somewhere and this
would be put into a such tank so that
means it's something like a dire
filtration but you're diluting it with
with your original protein concentration
the consequence is that you see
basically the uh the shape of the
profile is completely different but due
to this hybrid modeling approach and due
to the fact that we could take this
knowledge and we know how this works and
put it into the into the mechanistic
equations we are able to predict those
different uh operational modes and you
see here for example five models or five
different protein concentration you see
that the model and the predictions are
quite accurate in predicting the
duration of how long function process
would take as a function of the input
parameters and you see the same for the
batch tff and you see the same for the
fat batch tf1
in the second step or in the next step
basically you can take the same type of
model so you can take the same training
data to predict basically the duration
or to predict the conversion factor of
an sptff so
what is done here
is basically that we take the same
training data we just have to take we
just have to change the mechanistic
slightly in order to predict the
conversion factor for different uh
serial and parallel sptf system so it's
the same training data exactly the same
training data but what we learn here is
basically you see the experimental data
so the test experimental data in are
these thoughts and the model prediction
is basically are these lines so you see
how the conversion rate depending on one
two three membranes and the feed flow
rate basically changes and this is
already done asset from the initial
scouting from the data set initially so
you can really predict the uh the
conversion factor from a certain
membrane combination based on very
limited amount of training data and this
is the advantage for example if you have
in the manufacturing side
these proteins are quite expensive and
for for sptff development you often have
to consume a lot of these materials so
finding a way of how to predicting the
duration easier or faster or early on is
very helpful and here it says it's based
on a very limited amount of training
data which is then able to predict the
conversion rate for all of these
different uh different membrane types
and then you can take this for example
when you think about continuous bio bio
production you want to uh you have a
continuous buyer process and let's say
something in the input changes your
model basically knows if you have a
higher concentration how do you have to
adapt the feed flow how do you have to
adapt the pressure in order to get the
same to change the conversion rate in a
favorable condition that you then get
the same output at the end of your buyer
process and this can easily be done with
with such a model
so this helps you to basically reduce
development time I said it saves drug
substance because your your training
data is quite limited you don't need
that much data compared to an ordinary
sptf development
who get much better process
understanding because all of these
curves are there and then you see okay
what what is the change of how much do
this curves change if I increase the the
starting concentration how much does
this change in order of the feed flow so
all of this is basically intrinsic in
the model and as I said on the long run
it helps you also to enable advanced
process control because when you know
how these curves behave as a function of
changes in the input then you can re
revert it basically and take it for for
process control
the last thing here I want to show you
is basically Tire filtration so all of
the all of the things shown before are
already public it's published this is
still under development but you can see
for example
in entire filtration one of the problems
we often see is that the prediction of
the pH for example or the prediction uh
of certain materials in inside uh inside
the solution basically is not constant
over time or over dye filtration volume
and if you know for example incorporate
effects like the donut effect into your
mechanistic equations then you are also
able to describe this Behavior and then
you already know how many Tire
filtration volume you would take in
order to hit the certain pH or in order
to hit a certain exhibition
concentration
and these models can also help you help
you to to achieve this goal theorem
okay so well to summarize basically uh
everything I showed you so far is it's
really important that you consider the
whole workflow rather than just the
modeling approach it's really about
thinking about what do you want to do
with your models what are the
experiments I need to do and then
thinking about the modeling approach and
not just putting the modeling approach
in the first in the first line
uh nevertheless Hybrid models are a
sound basis to create a process model
and digital twins in silico
optimizations what I showed you with
this mdoa approach and this then helps
you significantly to save experimental
effort resources Manpower etc etc
you can take these Hybrid models also
for process scaling and you can take
these Hybrid models then for process
control so while in the Upstream for
example you can use it for monitoring
purposes quite easily in the downstream
you could use as I showed you with this
filtration topic you can take this type
of models in order to understand or in
order to change process parameters to
get always the same concentration at the
end of an sptff approach for example
finally if you're interested into using
this tool yourself you can basically use
your smartphone just just make a photo
of this um
this app you can download this this
toolbox basically and start modeling uh
for free with this tool in order to
describe your your process as much as
possible or as best as possible and to
save time
finally I'm at the end of my
presentation I want to thank you for
your time if you have any questions you
can always reach out to me on on
LinkedIn or just write me an email and
then we can have a discussion about if
you have any questions any modeling
questions or any other questions I'm I'm
happy to help you thank you very much
for your time and have a great day bye